oh look who it is high pitched powers
how are you i'm hearing some things
about you
what are you hearing i'm hearing gary
calls you you don't return his calls
you've been difficult
wow he refused to talk to wealthy he's
often too busy i hear these things i
don't like wolfy
because wolf is a dick okay i did a show
once in pennsylvania and wolfie was a
dick to me
i don't want to do anything with wolfie
eric it took me
30 emails to get you on the phone you
were busy you told me to call you after
your hernia operation at the end of june
but we finally got on the phone and i
said eric i would like you to talk to
sal he goes i want to talk to him
tomorrow
so why won't you talk to sal now because
that day
that was a month ago sal what do you got
to tell us we had this funny phone call
that we wanted to do this funny prank
call
i text eric hey can we do this can we
set up a date and he just gives me a
flat out no and i said why he goes i
just don't want to do anything
he won't even take chris wilding's call
and he's in love with chris
go ahead chris what happened eric's been
very very
nasty and rude to me over dm on twitter
this is outrageous
he threatened to block me on all social
media so i couldn't see any updates
about his life
i mean what is going on eric what is
going on with you
yeah you know why because you're not
gonna assess when you screw live with me
oh my god it was the middle of a
pandemic eric i haven't been anywhere
hold on i just went back and found an
old email right so i said eric um i
would like you to talk to cell and you
wrote back to me
no thank you what does that mean i was
busy at that time
cuz he would you do nothing he said he
was too busy because he was having lunch
a cigar and a nap
and i wouldn't be able to speak to him
and he got it now too howard he's
golfing
this is very exciting i play golf now
every wednesdays
yeah you got time for everything but us
if sam wants to do something with me
i'd be more than happy to do something
with him after one o'clock this
afternoon
i asked napkinette is on the phone what
do you want to say ed snapper's head is
a [ __ ] dick grass [ __ ]
[ __ ] kick ass that's all you do is
[ __ ] dick
yeah that's all you do is [ __ ] suck
people's dick
and why is that so bad yeah right ed
can i say something i think ed you're
smart
all of the listeners are now talking
about you high pitches out golfing never
calls into the show doesn't want to do
any bits and guess what's happening
you're starting to get big on cameo yeah
i hear you're busy with cameo
well i go i'm raising my price higher
than that [ __ ]
i bump up my prices for special
occasions you're broke
you're broke i'm not broke i'm not broke
well let me tell you something that i
like your whole thing where you're
giving people pep talks did you know
that high pitched ed gives people pep
talks he's becoming a motivational
speaker the way he's doing his thing
like tony robbins we want to encourage
you
about working i understand there's a
problem
about working well i'd rather do stuff
with sal and so if you want to call me
after
12 30 you can timing is everything eric
i've called you five times over the past
three weeks
you wouldn't do stuff with sal for weeks
phil why don't you call me
and we'll do something
we didn't want to bother you but would
you be open to that yeah let's get rid
of
eric sal do you think you can come up
with something for ed to do
in a heartbeat all right we'll put our
heads together right after the show
all right maybe do a little jam session
with that you're not golfing today are
you ed
no i'm not awful today i'm available
after 12.
i'm more than willing to do that that's
bad
it's between me and wolfie what is this
you're deciding which guys of mine
you'll talk to
wolfie calls you that's me calling you
my name is wolfie stern howard wolfie
stern
wolfie is me chris wilding is me sal is
not me but all right he should even talk
this out
thanks boss i will make myself available
you